hello chess fans i'm nick riscoe one of
the instructors at the st louis chess
club
and i'm here for chess openings
explained
tonight's opening is going to be the
tarte power defense which is in the
queen's gambit declined
now we've been looking over a lot of e4
openings
since uh i've taken over the class
figured it's time to switch it up
start to get into more of the positional
side of things
rather than openings that are based on a
lot of
attacks and tactics so
let's get right into it the target tower
like i said starts in the queen's gambit
declined so the first move we have
is d4 and black will play
d5 just making sure they have a share in
the center
as well as white now here
white will play pawn to c4 and this is
known as the queen's gambit
a very popular chess opening and the
idea is that if
black takes this pawn one way white may
continue is just play e4 right away
and they're already going to have
pressure and normally will win the pawn
back rather quickly now
this does give white a lot of space and
a lot of room to move around if black
takes
so a lot of the time you will see black
not take this
pawn and play e6 and this is known as
the queen's gambit declined
there are other moves here such as pawn
to c6 which leads itself to a slav
or yeah like i said just taking or
even knight to c6 the trigorin
so tonight we'll look at e6 and the most
popular way for white to continue
is with knight to c3
and the idea of knight to c3 is just
putting more pressure on the center
and you're also putting some support on
the e4 square
just in case white is able to get
through and play e4 right away
now black does have things to limit this
plan
mainly with knight f6 knight f6 just
puts more control on e4
so you can't just play pawn to e4 as
white
and the knight also puts more defense
on d5
now to get into the tartar tower white
needs to play bishop to g5 and this is
the most common move in this position
just pinning the knight to the queen and
this in turn is also removing
some of the defense from d5 so capturing
in the center
will force black to recapture with their
pawn
which can we'll see can affect their
structures in different ways later
now to maintain the defense on d5 we get
black playing bishop to e7
and this is breaking the pin it's
developing a piece
getting black ready to castle all good
so far
now white can play knight to f3
and black can follow with h6 now i do
want to make
a note that this move order is not
the only order of moves that can be
played to get to this position
you can see knight f3 being played
before knight c3
you can get bishop g5 coming later
you can see e3 played before knight f3
you can even see black castle before
playing h6 so this is
not the only move order but
a lot of move orders will lead to this
same position
i'm only bringing this specific move
order up though
because before black castles and black
plays h6
the main move is bishop to h4
but there's also the anti-tartakower
which is
bishop takes f6 and the idea is that
after
black takes back with the bishop you can
play pawn to e3
supporting the center opening up a line
for your bishop you get black castles
rook to c1 putting the rook on a file
which
is going to open rather quickly either
with white taking
or black taking black plays c6 to defend
and here black gets sort of this
semi-slav
type structure here you have these pawns
making a triangle
and your light square bishop is trapped
behind the pawn so
if black is not familiar with the ideas
in the semislav
this could be a little rough for them so
this is just some sideline they need to
watch out for
some common moves to develop here would
be bishop to d3
knight to d7 castles d takes c4
bishop takes c4 and black can get away
with an e5 break
here the pawn is sufficiently defended
and
shouldn't be too big of a deal if white
takes they can just recapture with
knight
white will play h3 he takes d4
e takes d4 and white gets this isolated
pawn
and we'll get a couple different looks
here at the hanging pawns
structure and the isolani pawn structure
and this here is a nice lani pawn
structure where there's this isolated
queen's pawn
and what white will normally try to do
is develop their pieces actively
and time a d5 push
knight to b6 is a way to continue open
up the diagonal for your bishop
while putting pressure on white
so you drop the bishop back to save it
bishop f5
bring the rooks to the e file trade the
rooks queen d2 queen d7 and rookie one
leads to
an equal position so
this is the anti-target hour this is
just something that black
should be aware of if they are going
with this move order
however like i said it does lead to a
very even position
and white can be a little bit more
ambitious if they leave
the the minor pieces on the board if
they go bishop h4
they retain the bishop pair and they'll
retain some
chances later on to build up pressure
so bishop h4 and castles
and now after e3 we see black play pawn
to b6
and this is our starting position for
the tartakower defense
here after b6 the idea is that this
light square bishop
is not having a great time on this
diagonal from c8 to h3
because of this pawn on e6 so to get
this light square bishop in the game
black please b6 and in almost every line
is going to go bishop b7 on the next
move
so what are white's options what kind of
plans can they go with
after b6 there's actually five pretty
decent
moves that white can choose from here
and i'm trying to see which one would be
the best one to show off
first i think we can go with one of the
older lines
queen to b3 so as far as i know
this one is probably the least popular
of the moves we're going to cover
however this is probably one of the
better
scoring options for white and i think
it's
well worth looking at giving it some
attention
so after queen b3 you are putting more
pressure
on the center and black goes bishop to
b7 reinforcing developing the bishop
pretty straightforward now we'll see
white
take on f6 and
i guess i want to ask why do we see the
bishop take on
f6 does anybody have any good ideas
why white would be okay giving up the
bishop pair
cassandra shock nice to see you again
why does white give up the bishop pair
all right we have one guess in the chat
remove a defender of e4
so white can push e4 we have another
guess
to reduce the number of defenders on d5
and uh was it ragnarok 56
actually hits it uh right away it says
black has to recapture on d5
with a pawn this is pretty important
that we force the recapture on d5 with a
pawn
um not to close the position
um i'm getting more more guesses in the
chat here
but it's not so you can close the
position if you end up playing c5
um okay black can't take but um
i mean you're not really threatening b6
the a pawn can just take back
but the point is that we want to try and
force black to have a
less than ideal pawn structure and once
this knight is off of f6
we can almost force black to have a
hanging pawns structure
we can take on d5 right away and the
pawn
should take if you take with the bishop
then
knight takes is not going to be um
i guess it shouldn't be a problem for
black but it's not ideal you kind of
want to keep that bishop
on the board because white's pawns on
the dark squares are doing a okay job at
stopping the dark square bishop and you
have
some holes in your your camp on the
queen side not saying that this is
you know losing there's some things to
be aware of
now moves like rook c1 hitting c7
is a nice way to add pressure bishop to
d3 just guess the bishop in the game
castles is easy
but with black it's a little hard to see
how you're going to expand on the queen
side if you go c6
and you move your knight well c6 is a
backwards pawn and you're going to
attack that
if you try and go c5 right away
uh sorry i guess it's white's move but
if you try and go c5 right away
then white can capture and force the
hanging pawns structure
so okay we take right away the e pawn
takes and now we get rook to d1
why rook to d1 this looks a little
awkward you would almost assume the rook
should go to c1
but here honestly it's kind of a bit of
a mystery move
but once we see the rook go to e8 and
bishop to d3
part of it is kind of to to support the
bishop make sure it's not hanging
also after c5 uh
if they play c5 which black should hear
then white takes with the pawn and now
after black
recaptures well okay sorry they can't
recapture
uh yeah this is one tactic that black
needs to worry about is the bishop
hanging
um so knight d7 here sorry
but now the rook is on an open file here
on d1
instead of on c1 um
but okay like i said we have to go
knight d7 here because
you can't take back right away after
knight d7
there's a couple tricks here that both
sides need to be aware of
it almost looks like white can get away
with just winning a pawn what happens if
they take
well if they take here this is actually
a little blunder
because it allows knight c5 and normally
allowing knight c5 is not an issue
because you can just go queen c2 and
then after the knight takes the bishop
you take back with the queen
but here queen takes b6 and
you have a quite a bit of pressure on
the queen side
and you can't just castle you'd really
like to castle
but the problem here is bishop to a6
and now you're being skewered your queen
has to move out of the way
and you're losing an exchange so
this just unfortunately doesn't work out
for white just because you don't get
that development in time
so trying to win the pawn is a big
mistake
instead you're going to lose this pawn
you might as well try and ruin
black's position with it while you can
you play c6 and now the bishop has to
take
we can also look at knight to c5 because
it
is attacking the queen but this is a
another trap
in the position that black can fall for
so i will leave it here see if any of
you guys can spot the tactic
knight c5 attacking the queen forking
queen and bishop
we just looked at this and this was good
for black in a similar line
but why does it blunder here
it is not uh so after queen c2 and they
capture
you can just recapture because then the
bishop can capture on c6 and there's not
much pressure
it's a little bit sharper and you have
to be okay with material imbalances
queen takes i guess you're looking at
queen takes d5
um queen takes d5
this move doesn't
work because bishop takes c3 with check
you have to resolve the check and once
you take you've lost your defender of
the queen
so it's not queen takes pawn and that's
just from
not being able to castle i guess
just white hasn't castled yet so queen
takes pawn
does not work
we do have someone in the chat who has
the correct answer
pawn takes b7 but nick
what are you doing your queen is hanging
well black takes the queen and now you
take on aa to make your own queen
and now after they take your queen on a8
you take the knight on b3
and if you take a look at the position
you have three minor pieces which
mathematically you know
three minor pieces worth three points
each will
add up to nine and then each side has a
rook
and now we see that there is a rook for
a bishop
so you're up two points of material as
far as pieces go
and as far as pawns go both of you guys
have six pawns so white is up
material here and according to stockfish
13
is at least plus two so you do have to
be good with material imbalances
understand how to use the pieces
to overpower the queen but uh here white
just has
too much excuse me too much material
so you can't go knight c5 here this is
why you must take on c6 with the bishop
and now after the bishop takes now white
finally gets to castle
trying to finish up some of the
development here now knight c5 here
you can just go queen to c2 and
rook to c8 kind of lining up the rook
with the queen
now with all of these pieces in the way
there's nothing you really need to worry
about
just yet if black tries to take the
bishop
white can recapture with the queen and
white is slightly better because of the
pressure on this isolated pawn
so that's why we see rook to c8 after
rook to c8 you can get knight to d4
and then after bishop d4 pawn takes
this is a equal position black can take
the bishop
if they want or they they can probably
move back but
uh in my opinion they should just take
the bishop
and after queen takes this is
equal position there's at least five
moves here black can play that are
equal so i guess this is where the game
starts
so that is what can happen after
queen to b3 some pretty straightforward
play
now someone's asking what happens if
black pushes d5 to d4
before white castles
um well at what point can they actually
play d4
right you capture on c5 they have to get
their material back somehow and knight
d7 is the only way to do so
and then you play c6 which is forking
some pieces
you have to take and then white castles
so
black actually doesn't get the chance to
play d5 to d4
before white castles
okay so instead of
queen to b3 let's take a look at some
more i guess
modern or more popular approaches to
this position
another line you can play which also
uh isn't as popular is
c takes d5
uh you know someone's asking knight d7
instead d4 in the previous line
aren't you just hanging material
instead of knight d7 they go d4
uh well first you can just go bishop c4
you add another attacker yes your knight
is hanging
but this is hanging with check so if
something okay they can't even take
because they hang the queen
like black's position is just starting
to fall apart here you're getting too
loose in the center you're falling
behind in development on the queen side
f7 is weak i i don't know what else you
want me to say
you're you're not winning your pawn back
anymore
black really needs to play knight d7 to
maintain equality
so they go d4 instead just bishop c4
attack f7
you get another piece attacking the pawn
all right hopefully we can all agree
that playing d4 as black is not good
on to the next choice for white is uh
taking on d5 after black plays b6
so you take on d5 and this forces black
to make a decision
either way they're going to have to take
on d5 with a pawn but are they going to
do it now or are they going to do it
later as in like one or two moves later
because you can also take with the
knight and this is the most popular way
black
plays is just takes with the knight and
what this does is makes a threat on the
bishop on
h4 they're threatening to win so you
have to resolve this threat first
take on e7 now knight takes c3 um
maybe kind of a potzer's try trying to
say
aha i got an extra move with my knight
i'm attacking your queen
but this is just losing you trade queens
and after knight 61 there is bishop e7
with a tempo
on the rook and if rook to e8
you can retreat the bishop and this
knight is trapped
there's nowhere this knight can go black
is going to be losing a piece
so watch out for that one you just take
on e7
and this forces them to recapture with
the queen
if the knight takes i mean this is
this is fine but you're undeveloping
your knight
and now after bishop to d3 white is a
bit ahead in development here
they have a little bit of space they're
ready to castle
it would make a lot more sense for the
queen to capture
and then bring your rook over to d8
so you see queen takes and now knight
takes d5
pawn takes d5
all right after these moves white can
play rook to c1
putting pressure on c7 and
now oddly enough instead of playing
bishop to b7 we get bishop to
e7 or sorry e6
and this is just controlling the center
maybe you're going to try and go c5 in
the future
but go bishop e6 this is the most
popular move
on the master level and queen to a4
i guess we should ask what happens if
bishop b7 and this isn't necessarily bad
but while you can just continue with
bishop d3
i guess you could play c5 and after
takes with the pawn takes with the pawn
white castles
there's no issues this is also an equal
position
but i think black has i believe black
has scored better with bishop e6
[Music]
at least it's been played what is it 900
more times so we're just going to go
with bishop e6
and queen a4 putting some pressure on
the position
get pawn c5 and rather than
then just take and take and give black
the hanging pawns right now
white has this move queen to a3
and this puts pressure on c5 they cannot
just take on d4
because the queen would hang on e7
so this does pin it black should play
rook to ca to give it a little bit more
defense
and now whites can just finish their
development with bishop to e2
after the queen goes to f8 breaking this
pin now we capture on c5
pawn captures and white can castle and
this two
is also a fairly equal position black
would probably benefit most from
developing the knight to d7
and adding more defense
so this is one of the ways you can go
with c takes d5 and this is a rather
forcing approach
it's pretty straightforward as well
usually you know if the knight takes you
have to take on e7 and resolve this
threat first
and then uh pin on c5 later
and then uh finish your development
okay so that was c takes d5
what other moves are there here rook to
c1 is a
pretty good move this was played by
was it short i believe it was short who
played this
um but after rook to c1
black normally continues bishop to b7
and now we take on f6 with the same idea
as before
is that you're removing a defender of d5
so that way when you take they have to
take with the pawn
and again you don't really want to take
with the bishop mainly because of knight
takes
and okay queen takes is fine but uh
bishop c4 is already going to come with
tempo
once the queen goes back just castles
and white is
just miles ahead in development here
we take pawn takes and b4
this is another idea you will get in the
tartar power from white
is uh if they're not fighting in the
center to give the hanging pawns
they can also go b4 and this prevents
c5 so black goes c6 instead
and now you got bishop d3 queen d6 and
queen b3
so you can also see this queen side play
and one of the ways this may develop his
knight to d7 castles
a5 a3 defending we see a trade
and bishop to e7 attacking the pawn and
white is going to do fine
after rook to b1 after rook b1 rook fie
to this position
is just so slightly better for white
after rook f to e1
but very very slightly
so that is one way you can continue with
rook 2 c1 rook to c1 is going to focus
more on this b4
play with queen side development
okay there are two other moves in this
position
that deserve attention and
let's check the masters database real
quick to see which one
is played more often so the other two
moves you have
is bishop to d3 and you also have bishop
to e2
now what are the differences between
these bishop moves you're developing the
same
uh piece but to different squares why
would one person
want to go an extra square well
i guess we'll look at bishop e2 first
because it's not as popular
but one of the ideas you have is that
if they take on c4 it doesn't come with
tempo on the bishop
so white does have an extra move to just
kind of
castle if they want and take back later
although most popular is taking back
right away
that question in the chat are kingside
attacks effective
in these lines um
i it's hard to to say i haven't seen any
king side attacks work
early on mainly because both sides are
fighting in the center
and here in d4 uh with d4
openings you're going to be less likely
to find these
big grand attacks just coming right away
where you're throwing your pawns up the
board on the king side
trying to checkmate just because with d4
you're not opening as many lines for
your pieces as early
so i wouldn't recommend trying to go for
those attacks
with d4 openings it seems most of the
plans to just take it slow
play positionally build up a small
advantage
build on that i'm not going to say that
d4 is
all that because there are some sharp
openings like the grunfeld
but for the most part and especially
here it's going to be a bit more of a
classical approach to the position
okay so we're going to take a look at
bishop to e2
black continues with bishop to b7
and again we get a capture on f6
bishop captures c takes d5
e takes d5 by now excuse me by now we're
starting to notice that these
uh are standard moves in the position
and here with bishop to e2 we can also
see this b4 expansion
and after b4 black has two moves here
one is c6 which is like what we just
looked at with
the rook c1 lines but there's
also the opportunity for them to play c5
and part of this is because white's rook
is not on c1 adding extra pressure
and if c5 is played and white takes
black takes back and white can go
rook to b1 here white is not going to be
looking to take back on c5 because of
bishop c3
check and you're losing a massive amount
of material
that you can resign after taking so you
have to let this sit
but you go rook b1 part of this is so
that way if you do capture
there's no pin but this doesn't protect
the knight so you still can't capture
and now we see bishop to c6 just
defending the bishop
moving it out of harm's way
moving on from here white is going to
castle
finish up some development black will
continue developing with knight d7
and now white is going to trade off the
light square bishops with bishop to b5
and queen c7 just defending the bishop
you can take
this is fine this will lead to a equal
game
and this is what you can look forward to
if you play bishop
to e2
now that's with c5 which again is kind
of an exception because the rook is not
on c1
but the main move is c6
after c6 white castles and we get rook
to e8
after rook to e8 we now see queen b3
which is following those ideas of
expanding on the queen side
and black will try and hit white with
a5 now in the other line we saw white
play
pawn to a3 and this is still playable
but black can just move the knight
develop
and unless white is capturing can't
really take advantage of this backwards
b-pawn
if you do take they're just going to
take with the rook
so with a5 rather than play a3
you just take right away and then after
rook takes you can go a4
this is kind of limiting the space that
the rook has to operate on
stopping any type of rook to b5
even though there are pieces controlling
this square already there's limiting the
rook
gaining some space on the queen side and
now we see knight d7 uh putting control
on b6 um i guess you can
probably also try rook to b1 here as
well
uh and you're met by knight d7 because
it's the only move that protects this
pawn
and this is another line you can go down
but i like a4 just getting this space
back
at knight d7 again and now rook f2 e1
so you're getting this rook off of f1 in
case you need to drop the bishop back
for any
any reason here and if they play
c5 maybe you can allow them to take and
you take back and it's on an open file
but it's it's another one of those kind
of mysterious rook moves
we get queen to a8 bishop to d3
which is kind of controlling the back
rank over here
the rook is ready to help e4 maybe get
played in the future
and now black has enough protection on
c5 from the knight
the rook and the pawn that they can play
c5 right away
after c5 and go bishop b5
pin the knight to the rook and the
logical move is rook d8 just protect it
and break the pin
now takes takes and queen takes b6
so white looks to be going up a pawn in
this line
after bishop to c6 your queen is
starting to run low on squares
uh you can't go rook b7 that would hang
the bishop but
rook a6 might look a little scary
and here rook a2 b1 maybe you can try
and trade the queens
but black is building up a lot of
pressure on this a pawn looking to win
this
for the b pawn that they gave up and
yeah i think you're just going to lose
this pawn anyway so bring your rook to
the open file and king h7 has been
played here
before this was played in 2018
there's a game here played in 2018 it
was a draw
between rain and diaz
um so that's probably all the engine
prep there
for queen e2
that the game did follow uh almost all
engine prep
uh and then i guess the last move here
bishop
to d3 and this is what you'll see most
people play in the tartar tower this is
the main line all the other moves were
were sidelines except for bishop e2
bishop e2 is a bit more of a serious try
but bishop d3 is
the most popular next to bishop e2
okay bishop d3 scroll down in my notes
here
and you guessed it black plays bishop to
b7 now
uh i did mention some people might play
bishop e2 to avoid
this capture coming with tempo so let's
do take a look at what happens if black
takes
if black takes this is no problem for
white
white can just take back with their
bishop
and now we get bishop to b7 and castles
if they ever capture on f3 currently
your queen can recapture
no big deal knight 2 d7
queen to e2 again making sure the
queen can recapture the knight and also
connecting your rooks so your rooks can
go to d1 and c1
and now we get this move that reminds me
of the queen's indian
knight to e4 looking to maybe trade the
knights off the board
and here you can either take the knight
or take on e7
one of the moves that i have just to
show an example is bishop to g3 because
this is a move you'll see in other lines
as well
just retreating the bishop can be a bit
better of a move than trading
pieces off the board and if they do take
on g3
you just take back with your h pawn your
structure is still
very sound pawn to
c5 and rather than take the pawn
if you do take with the pawn black is
going to be happy to take with either
the bishop
or the knight both of these will improve
the minor pieces
taking with knights is probably better
because if the bishop is on c5 it's
pointing
at these pawns and it's not going to
have the range you want it to
but taking with the knight should be
fine for black so rather than take
and allow black to develop you can go
rook f to d1
and here for some reason the most played
move is bishop takes f3
and i'm not the biggest fan of this move
and the engine isn't either
but this is the most played move in the
masters database
if you take with the queen
then it's pretty equal but if you take
with
the pawn white has a pretty substantial
advantage here of almost
plus one and it's after takes on d4
e takes on d4 you still have this
shelter around your king you can go
king g2 maybe rook to h1 might be an
idea
try and focus on the h file but this
seems to have no
problems for white at all
knight to f6 and now you can play d5
if e takes knight takes oh not the
bishop
knight takes and after knight takes
it's hard to find a fantastic move for
black because if you take
bishop takes d5 this is actually a fork
for those of you who don't see it well
first
you're hitting the rook that's pretty
obvious but the second part
is bishop takes f7 with check
and it's key that this comes with check
because it is also a discovery
on the queen so
this is a fork threatening the rook and
threatening
bishop f7 check with a discovery
on the queen so you can't take on d5
with the knight
you can improve slowly with bishop c5
but we can get some queen side expansion
from white tier
b4 right away defended by the knight
and here white just has the space the
king is safe the queen and rook are
doing a good job on the open files
and black is still struggling to find
the best place for their queen and
queenside rook
so here this line i don't think
works out for black just quite but that
is just after
bishop takes f3 uh rather than take on
f3 with the bishop
black should probably just keep the
pieces on the board
you can go knight f6 and if white takes
then
queen to c7 and okay
it looks like you can try to take right
away
and give up this uh sorry not give up
the bishop
it is defended um white just gets this
pawn over here
in return black does have these pretty
active pieces
so this is a pawn sacrifice black could
go ahead with
it's a bit better than just taking on f3
so that's just if they take on c4 now
you know what to do
that being said black doesn't normally
take on c4 here
instead they just go bishop to b7
regular normal development
and white continues by castling so
this is one of those lines where white
actually castles what seems early
compared to what we've been looking
at before but white can castle here
knight to d7 is the most played move
and now white should play queen to e2 uh
i know when i i went through a weird
awkward phase where i played d4
and uh here i like played rook c1 which
is still fine
but in order to make sure your rooks are
getting to the correct files
you don't know if it's c c1 and d1 or d1
and e1
queen e2 is just a very flexible move
that allows either of those setups
and in addition to maintaining
flexibility for your rook
placement and having them connected this
also gives you
some support of an e4 push if you can
get
through with it like if black is just
playing very sloppily
getting e4 in should should be good for
white
so queen e2 and here they can play c5
or they can play knight to e4 and they
do
transpose into each other but i'm going
to explain
the difference here is that um
okay 94 is probably better if they go c5
white has many moves here and they
actually
you know can capture in the center
either on c5
or capturing on d5 countering on d5 is a
little bit better
but because of these captures in the
center white can
kind of mess up black structure a little
bit and black needs to be prepared
for any of these possible moves white
can make rather than try and
hope white plays the main line knight e4
is a little bit more forcing
knight e4 and you can go bishop to g3
and that's what i recommend you can also
take on e7
and this is definitely playable queen
captures
takes on d5 takes on d5 and then
rook f to d1 or rook
i guess f to c1 you can probably go rook
a to c1 as well
there's a lot of good moves here um
but like i said i think bishop to g3 is
also fine
knight takes pawn takes no problem here
black would probably continue with
knight to f6 and you can capture in the
center like normal
you'll probably get night captures and
the only difference here is that if you
do capture on d5 a lot
this doesn't hurt black because they
don't have to take with the pawn and
this is what black is looking for
um knight d5 is fine whenever white
can't trade enough to force
e takes d5 so this is fine so rather
than
um i guess allow that
black can also go c5 right away
uh it's like i said taking on g3 is okay
but they also have c5 right away this is
your main line here
and we get c takes d5 e takes d5
and now rook a to d1
why doesn't black play d take c4 to open
his
light square bishop
uh let's see let's see if we can find a
good opportunity where black can play
this
you do want to develop the knight if you
take right away
then again we can just take and there's
no big problems here
you play c5 you play c5 i can take
bishop takes and now queen e2 i'm gonna
get the open file
so you can open it up but i think the
center opens up in a way that's
favorable for white
at least in this position
if you wait until after queen e2 again
just after bishop takes you're doing
fine
and you still have knight e4
but yeah like i said um i don't think
there's any real problem with it it's
just the center kind of opens up to
benefit white
they're a little bit quicker at getting
those rooks on that open file
and you don't want your queen to be
tempoed by those rooks
you want to make sure that you can
develop all of your pieces first in
order to contest that file
at the proper time you don't want to
open the center prematurely
so knight d7 queen to e2
and knight to e4 which leads into this
main line a bit more forcingly
a bit more forceful and now we get c5
after c5 like i said takes on d5 takes
on d5
i guess black what if they try to take
instead of moving the knight up
yeah we just looked at this yeah just
taking is no problem they can still go
knight e4
but you can just trade everything off
and then rook f to d1 this rook's going
to come to c1
and white is done with development and
black's pieces are
probably not probably not placed on
their best squares
it's probably an argument it's the only
move black has
that gives them a good good attack here
is just c5
but rook a c1 white is just ahead in
development
um if you're asking after knight to e4
and takes on g3
so it takes takes and now they take
again
there's no problem here the queen is
still on d8
so if there's any type of c5 i can take
here black's probably best to go c6
is 94 played to prevent b3
um no 94 is played to
trade off a set of miners which can be
good for black because they're down a
little bit of space
not too much they still have very good
control over here
but it's not really played to prevent b3
i mean i don't think white is ever
trying to play b3 i think white's trying
to be a little bit more ambitious and
play b4 if possible
not possible with the bishop on e7 but i
i don't think that this is what white is
even trying to go for in the first place
because a lot of the times you'll see
white just capture on d5
and open up the center for the rooks i
don't think you're trying to go b3
let black take and white takes back with
the pawn
because you'd much rather have the c and
d file than
the b file and either c d or e file
you want your rooks to be as close to
the center as possible
we have another question how do you
ensure that you are covering the color
complex of the fianchetto bishop of the
opponent
that if you're trying to touch on color
complexes you should probably be taking
lessons from a gm
and probably have a rating over 2000 at
least
um color complex isn't even something
that
i'm trying to touch in this there really
isn't much to worry about from this
bishop as long as your knight on f3 is
protected by the queen
and right now there's not much to worry
about because it's blocked by its own
pawn
so as far as the grand scheme of things
on the board
worrying about the color complex of this
bishop is like the least of my concern
trying to focus on the pawn structure
and control in the center
is going to be a bit more important
okay back into the main line hopefully
we covered all the questions
we get c5 by black just
fighting in the center and c takes d5
e takes d5 rook a to d1
and now here black can take on
g3 and white we'll just take back with
the h pawn
there is another alternative here with
queen to c8
and this has been played before back in
2007
um by vasily ivanishik so
he goes queen c8 and the way that this
game continued was uh
rook goes to c1 and it's a little odd
because we just put that rook on d1 what
are we doing moving the rook again
well this is now lined up with the queen
so there is a little bit of risk if
black opens up the center
they go rook f to d8 rook f2 d1
and now you get the c and d files uh
when before you're probably going to get
the d
and e files so the files have shifted
over one which is probably a little good
because this is where the files are
going to open up
knight d to f6 and knight e5
just getting the knight into the center
queen e6 was played
bishop h4 trying to avoid this capture
maybe capture on f6 rook a to c8
and i'll just play through some of these
moves so you can see how the game
developed but most of the pieces got
traded off here
and ended the game ultimately ended in a
draw
but they reached this position and
played on
but queen c8 yeah a lot of the pieces
can trade off here and lead to an equal
position
so i think if black's trying to keep
chances be a little bit more ambitious
take on g3 with the knight and after h
takes g3
um i'm gonna recommend queen c7 here and
this is where i guess a lot of the
theory
kind of dissipates not too many people
have had games in this line
where it continues from here but now you
should have a
solid basis for how to play against the
tartakower defense
and to play it as black what white tries
to do
is get black into a hanging pawns
structure
where if you're a less experienced
player can be a little bit
weak those pawns can be a liability
because they have to be defended by
pieces
but an experienced player probably
shouldn't see
too many problems having the hanging
pawns and be able to use them to push
forward effectively
um yeah so that's that's it i think um
it's a little bit of a difficult opening
for black if you don't know what you're
doing but
as long as you have some preparation
against all the white's lines i don't
think you have any real trouble
definitely a very interesting balanced
opening but i'll open up our last five
to ten minutes here
for any more questions that come through
i know we had a lot of them come through
during the lecture but maybe that
inspired some of you to have your own
questions
um yeah any questions taking them now
ben do you ever have any questions
no ben doesn't have any questions ben's
a super strong chess player
pandemic is silence to me
ben's so strong he doesn't he doesn't
need to watch the actual lecture he just
does a great job editing
all right so i'm trying to see if i
missed any lines
here oh i think we covered it all
this black doesn't take on c4 too early
just focus on the development of their
pieces white tries to mess up
black's pawn structure ben simon or ben
feingold
neither of the bends need my opening
classes
no i was talking about ben simon
f5 ever does black
ever play f5 um
i haven't seen any line where they play
f5 but let me go through and see
if there's a line where that's even
possible
go through the moves
i guess the first time you may consider
f5 is here
because this is the first move where
it's really possible but i don't
see what f5 is getting you
actually maybe you can argue you're
getting space on the king side
but i mean if white's smart they're not
going to take on e4
and walk into this fork um
i guess they can take on d5 and you want
to take with the pawn
and now you have knight e5
so nick weiss you're saying a lot of
moves g5 g4
but what is this actually gaining you g5
g4 isn't attacking anything
there's 95 here this is a pretty strong
move you're trying to stop knight g6 so
you almost have to take and now bishop
e5
and now your chance to get the bishop
pair is gone
yeah i think with the bishop over here
on b7
putting your pawns on the light squares
like this is not going to help your
bishop
so yeah f5 here doesn't seem to work out
you don't have enough pieces in the game
um
yeah white takes you take 95 what else
can you try here
and you can't go knight f6 just because
knight g6 is too strong
so i guess it's a good question but it
just doesn't work out
with probably one or two pieces on the
queen side that you'd rather have in the
center king side
yeah and once the pawn is off of e6 f5
probably doesn't
make as much sense just because of
knight e5
if c takes d4 you take back with the
knights
um so where's black
capturing on d4
right here uh yeah here you would take
back with um
the knight knight takes d4 because your
rook is already on the d-file
and you don't want to block it with the
pawn
and you might look at moving your rook
over to c1 and the other rook to d1
so yeah if they take on d4 taking back
with the knight
is probably ideal
great wolf is saying the idea worked for
white when playing the london i'm
assuming you're talking about the f5
lines
what's the difference between the
tartakower and the queen's indian
good question so with the queen's indian
white is going to have a bit of a
different setup so first
the move order is different you get
knight f6 first and after
c4 e6 you get knight f3 and then b6
and in the queen's indian white
usually plays g3 followed by bishop g2
so white's going to have a different
pawn structure they're going to go
bishop g2 contest this diagonal
and give it a different flavor
so good question i know sometimes with
the move orders
i believe they can transpose between one
another
but i think they're more like cousins
than um being like the same like
brothers
but very good question
all right uh any more questions we'll
give it another
probably two or three minutes and
wrap it up here so last minute questions
man i am curious about this f5 move
i don't know i just don't see how you're
compensating for the space and control
white gets
what's my feed aerating and am i
planning to become a gm
i'm not feed a rated yet and i might be
too old
to try and become a gm but uh national
master
if i die and i'm not a national master
i'll be sad
well i'll be dead
why do i put the rook on d1 if i'm going
to move it to c1 anyway
yes very good question bless p
i did cover this a little bit but the
reason you put it on d1
is because you're looking to capture on
c5 and give black a hanging pawn
structure so if you're looking to take
on c5 a rook on d1 makes a lot of sense
um and like there was a comment
earlier if they take on d4 you just take
back with the knight your rook is well
placed against
their queen and you already have some
pressure on the pawn
but yeah if you go
c1 this is also playable don't think
this is a bad move
this is still fine it's just if you take
and they take back with the knight you
might have some problems
trying to get the knight off of that
file
no there's no age limit to become a
grand master i just think i'm a little
too old
in the fact that i may not have the time
to become a grand master
if i was like 12 and i only did school
and
the rest of my time i did chess maybe
there's some hope
but with me being a college student and
working
there might just not be enough time for
me to become
a grandmaster
why don't we move the other rook to d1
again this is also playable they can
take on g3 you take back
um looks like they can take or not take
but
play c4 and close up the position
bishop c2 makes sense here
why not the other rick why why are they
playing c4 in this line instead of in
this line
uh you take
take knight d2 what is the difference
here
it was a good question c4
let's get to the bottom of this why
i i don't think i can honestly give an
answer for why one look over the other
that's a very good question that'll be
your guys's homework assignment figure
it out and you tell me in the comments
section below
yeah i i really wish i could give you an
answer but some of these rook moves on
the back rank honestly are a little
suspicious to me
the the moves that i gave for my
recommendations are ones that come from
master games and what masters play the
most
that's a pretty good comment blessed p
there saying that uh
no matter how you arrange your rooks
whichever rook you move first
odds are that black can change the
structure or the structure is going to
change where white
is going to have to spend a tempo to
adjust anyway um
but i don't think that's a huge problem
because white is
has probably better piece placement in
my opinion that
spending another move to adjust your
rooks is not the end of the world
with rook a to d1 you have the option of
bishop to b1
that's a pretty good point that if you
do go
rook to d1 and they go c4
well first you do want to take because
the pawns are going to be too weak but
yeah bishop to b1
is another option and now your rook
isn't going to be trapped in the corner
so that's pretty good observation
yeah yeah great wolf i think that's a
very nice point
but all right we are hitting our time
limit here so unfortunately we won't be
able to take any more questions
but you guys have a lot of great ones
tonight um
i will see you guys next week for
openings explained if there are any
other questions i didn't get into make
sure to drop them into the comments
section below
we're gonna head over to twitch to wrap
up the winners circle i'll see you guys
over there have a good night
[Music]
you